let's do number two when it comes to
drugs alcohol and other addictives we
get a lot of
guys out there that will point and
sputter at those that might
drink and others might point sputter at
those that
consume cannabis and they're at each
other it's all the same thing guys
if you have a drinking problem if you
have an addiction problem
whether that's to shopping returning
things at stores
drugs recreational drugs that run your
life prescription drugs
any of these addictives i'm just going
to classify them all as addictives
are ultimately coming from toxic people
these guys that can't
make something again i have to watch my
language here
you have to be able to walk away from
things and make it your
bi tch okay people often say hey you
know is there anything wrong with
uh smoking adobe every once in a while
no it's legal
it's completely legal you can buy it
from the state now you know the
government sells it here in ontario
many places in the world it's completely
legal there's nothing wrong with it but
does it run your life
are you on it all the time can you like
is it something that enhances what it is
that you're doing
there's other people that it's not it's
it's a complete detriment it's an anchor
for them
right alcohol in my opinion is probably
one of the worst
a lot of people will be like oh you know
i'm very healthy and i work out look at
me and i'm a strong guy and all this
sort of stuff but they guzzle
alcohol like it's going out of style i
don't care
if you're doing it for showmanship
purposes because you're cracking
bottles of bubbly and you know expensive
whiskey's been there done it who cares
it's not impressive these are all
addictives okay
these are things that toxic people allow
to consume and run their lives you need
to get good
at avoiding them it's quite simple
people that are into addictives and
again i'm going to repeat that guys it's
not just drugs and alcohol
it's also people that have personality
issues that are addictive
um i dated this girl once that used to
have an addiction to buying stuff
bringing it home and then returning it
i'm not even kidding
buy four lamps there's one end table
and she'd have to try them all out on
the table and the ones that she didn't
like should return them back to the
store
three would go back to the store one
would stay sometimes not even one would
stay all four would go back because they
wouldn't fit the decor of the room or
something like this
this is an addictive okay when you spot
these peoples
these people arm's length it's as simple
as that
they're not a sale you know they're not
going to fill your sail with wind and
carry you forward to your next port of
call these people are anchors they're
going to hold you back
they're an energy vampire
you